bienvenue dans le débat de France 24 on
va revenir ce soir sur cette victoire
historique de Lula au second tour de la
présidentielle au Brésil à 77 ans
l'ancien président de gauche revient au
pouvoir pour un troisième mandat 12 ans
après l'avoir quitté une victoire de
justesse avec 50,9% des voix face au
chef de l'État sortant d'extrême droite
Jr bolsonaro GR bolsonaro qui d'ailleurs
n'a toujours pas pris la parole il doit
s'exprimer dans la journée selon l'art
de ses alliés après une campagne
extrêmement violente et polarisée Lula
pourra-t-il réunir les Brésiliens quid
du bolsonarisme quel sera ça marche de
manœuvre face à un congrès dominé
aujourd'hui par les conservateurs
sera-t-il en mesure de redresser la
première économie d'Amérique latine
quelle place pour le Brésil de Lula sur
la scène internationale on va en
débattre ce soir avec nos invités
Virginie Jacob berger l'avouée
journaliste aux échos auteur de Brésil
voyage au pays de bolsonaro aux éditions
du Rocher Virginie Jacob berger bonsoir
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous François
Michel Letourneau à vos côtés géographes
aussi NRS spécialiste du Brésil et de
l'Amazonie bonsoir Armel Anders
historienne du Brésil à l'Université
Paris 8 bonsoir également et puis parce
Skype depuis Sao Paulo Joao Whitaker
membre du Parti des Travailleurs proches
de Fernando Haddad ancien maire de Sao
Paulo architecte et directeur aussi de
la faculté d'urbanisme à l'Université de
Sao Paulo bonsoir Joao Whitaker
j'aimerais j'aimerais qu'on revienne
d'abord sur l'annonce de la victoire de
Lula c'était cette nuit et c'est
partisans vous allez voir on célébrait
ces résultats on va voir aussi les
déclarations de Lula juste après
l'annonce de sa victoire regardez
le geste de la victoire et du
soulagement
l'oula est élu président pour la
troisième fois un retour historique et
des millions de partisans qui lament
[Musique]
un peu plus tôt à l'annonce des
résultats une immense émotion
la victoire est serrée 50,9% pour le
candidat de gauche et 49,1 pour son
adversaire jaillit volsonaro
c'est un sentiment de soulagement de
joie on a beaucoup souffert et moi je
suis sorti tous les jours pour militer
et essayer de faire basculer l'élection
je réussis
à 77 ans Louis signation lou la DA SILVA
c'est son nom complet avant sereinement
vers la scène pour prendre la parole
féliciter par son entourage proche
merci merci à tous
[Musique]
le Brésil est ma priorité le peuple et
ma cause est combattre la misère et la
raison pour laquelle je vivrai jusqu'à
la fin de mes jours
dans le camp de l'extrême droite c'est
la stupeur
jaillir bolsonaro a perdu avec un écart
de seulement 2 millions de voix sur 156
millions d'électeurs l'écart le plus
serré de l'histoire de la démocratie
brésilienne
Lola ne sera pas en mesure de gouverner
ces programmes qui incluent l'avortement
la violence et la drogue ne passeront
pas l'étape du Parlement
pour l'heure jaillir bolsonaro que l'on
voit ici juste après le vote n'a pas
encore reconnu sa défaite il est enfermé
dans son palais de l'alvorada à Brasilia
on vient de le voir c'est une victoire
sur le fil pour Lula c'était avant tout
un vote contre jaillir bolsonaro contre
le président sortant d'extrême droite
c'est une victoire pour la démocratie
est-ce que vous êtes soulagé
oui bien sûr bonsoir On est tous très
soulagés je pense que c'est un vote qui
est un peu divisé il y a une base de
vote de Lula qui est déjà traditionnelle
autour de 30% peut-être que le parti de
travailleur a toujours eu mais Lola a su
effectivement élargir cette base
aidez beaucoup par le propre président
bolsonaro qui ces derniers mois a
augmenté énormément toutes les bravades
contre la démocratie toutes ces
démonstrations d'autorité etc ce qui a
aidé un peu à composer un front beaucoup
plus ample et beaucoup plus démocratique
qui en fait a exprime exprimé hier
selon l'envie de ne plus avoir cette
engouffrement dans la dans la tragédie
de la barbarie que l'on était en train
de de subir au Brésil
Jacob berger se Front démocratique comme
l'appelle jouant whithécker finalement
il l'a emporté que de justesse
0,9% de plus 2 millions de voix
seulement de plus que j'ai air bolsonaro
c'est très peu c'est l'écart le plus
serré plus la fin de la dictature ça
vous étonne que ce résultat il soit si
serré alors ça m'étonne pas parce que je
suis quand même le Brésil depuis un
petit moment et puis j'étais pour les
échos j'étais sur place et qu'est-ce que
ça signifie ça signifie on l'a beaucoup
souligné c'est quand même un Brésil
malheureusement complètement polarisé
moi j'ai vraiment vu la différence entre
le le la campagne de cette année comparé
au mandat de 2018
ou à cette époque il y avait vraiment
l'envie d'un rejet de la corruption des
parties en place et bolsonaro se dire
que c'était comme ça un peu un chevalier
blanc même si c'était absolument pas le
cas parce qu'il était député depuis 30
ans et on peut pas dire qu'il a sans
doute enfin en tout cas il avait pas de
de charge de corruption donc ce qu'il a
aidé à lui se faire passer pour comme ça
une nouvelle voix il a promis de régler
toute la le problème la corruption de la
et sur cette promesse là il a été élu
dans une réaction vraiment de rejet
contre la gauche qui était au pouvoir et
les parties alliées donc ça c'était le
Brésil de 2018 où aujourd'hui à c'est à
dire qu'à cette époque il y a encore 4
ans vous imaginez c'est pas non plus une
éternité il y avait encore un Brésil qui
se parlait des Brésiliens qui certes
n'avaient pas les mêmes idées mais
discuter échanger s'engueuler peut-être
enfin voilà mais aujourd'hui on se
déchire même un pays totalement fracturé
mais même dans les dans les familles
j'ai des contacts que j'ai quand même
entretenu et puis après bon je suis allé
dans tous les dans beaucoup de bureaux
de vote donc j'ai vu des gens aussi bien
aisés que dans les communautés ce qu'on
appelle les communautés c'est donc les
favelas et et donc des populations très
diverses et dès que vous entrez un peu
dans leur entourage il y a vraiment des
gens ils ne parlent plus un oncle il
parle plus à un cousin c'est ça ce qui
s'est passé au Brésil pourquoi il faut
quand même là un moment donné dire qui
est responsable de cette situation de la
même manière que Trump complètement
vraiment agiter les braises sur vraiment
avec le côté populiste et diviser son le
peuple américain c'est alors d'une autre
manière le Brésil a bien évidemment ses
spécificités mais je suis désolé
l'étiquette de Trump tropical elle est
pas venue pour rien effectivement lui
dans sa stratégie en tout cas politique
c'est ce qu'il a essayé de faire il a
essayé de diviser les gens et ça n'a
fait que et ça a marché fracturé quoi et
sur le score qui effectivement est quand
même très faible sur un pays de 215
millions d'habitants je pense que ce
qu'il faut dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui
quand même il faut voir que Lula à la
victoire à l'arracher mais il a la
victoire et on peut dire moi j'ai quand
même un interrogé cette nuit même à
distance parce que tous on était
suspendus sur cette élection vous savez
il y a même des gens qui ont voté
peut-être Lula qui sont pas du PT et qui
sont dit il faut vraiment que
c'est aujourd'hui c'est vraiment un
front pour beaucoup ça a été on veut
absolument passer c'est à autre chose et
moi ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé cette
nuit vous le vote correspond enfin votre
interlocuteur en parlait sur ce
sentiment de soulagement c'est à dire
que cette nuit on a tous eu l'impression
d'un Brésil qui suspendait sa
respiration pour reprendre autre chose
alors ceci étant je pense qu'il faut
aussi souligner que Lula aujourd'hui
arrive à ce score mais qu'il est dans un
pouvoir de coalition où il a il a fait
coalition avec un vice-président qui est
plutôt de centre et puis le Congrès
aujourd'hui
on va l'aider à négocier et puis Lula
est plutôt un habile négociateur on va
en reparler de ça comment il va faire
justement pour pour faire avancer les
choses au Brésil Armel Henders ce score
si serré ça ça montre quoi selon vous ça
montre que finalement le bolsonarisme il
s'est il s'est un peu enraciné dans la
société brésilienne pendant pendant ces
années de gerbolsonaro pouvoir oui ça ça
vient d'être dit alors la polarisation
elle était déjà très forte en 2018 il y
avait déjà des gens qui se parlaient
plus mais là c'était très violent sur
cette campagne et et non c'est là il y a
vraiment deux pays qui se regardent Lula
a commencé ainsi d'ailleurs son discours
hier en disant voilà les Brésiliens se
sont prononcés sur deux projets de pays
totalement différents après il a proposé
de transcender cette différence mais ça
sera extrêmement difficile c'est des
visions du monde qui sont qui s'opposent
et le soulagement c'est parce que pour
tous ceux qui ont voté Lula même sans
être péthisme même sans aimer Lula même
sans c'est la sensation d'avoir échappé
au gouffre la démocratie avec un
deuxième mandat de bolsonaro c'était un
point de non-retour pour pour l'Amazonie
mais je pense que c'est pas seulement ça
qui qui préoccupait les gens c'était les
institutions le fait de de renverser la
Cour suprême enfin de de mettre enfin de
passer à une dictature parce que c'est
malgré tout le projet de c'est pas tout
à fait un Traum tropical c'est il a
quelque chose de plus c'est quelqu'un
pour qui la dictature militaire n'est
pas une nostalgie mais un projet à finir
en fait qui était l'élimination de la de
ce qu'il appelle la gauche ce qui est
extrêmement vaste François Michel
Letourneau la démocratie brésilienne
elle a été sauvée cette nuit alors je
pense que elle va mieux effectivement en
même temps le soulagement est dans le
camp de Lula il est pas dans le camp des
bolsonaristes donc on a aussi une partie
du Brésil qui n'est pas soulagée du tout
et je pense que ce qu'il faut remarquer
aussi c'est que quand on était cet été
les sondages donnaient une très ample
victoire à Lula ça s'est beaucoup
resserré au fur et à mesure donc ce
qu'on ce dont on s'aperçoit c'est que il
y a les gens qui étaient en faveur de
bolsona bien sûr mais aussi beaucoup de
gens qui étaient contre Lula et donc
dans quelle mesure est-ce qu'il va
pouvoir tendre la main à ses jambes
il est associé malgré tout par une
partie de la population Bré deviennent à
la corruption il a été blanchi il a été
blanchi mais bon son gouvernement a
quand même été le fameux député
d'extrême droite Roberto Gerson qui
vient d'être qui s'est illustré
récemment en tirant sur les policiers
était un ancien allié de loups lors de
ce gouvernement condamné pour corruption
dans un schéma qui était organisé par le
PT donc voilà des gens se souviennent de
ça il y a malgré tout auprès d'une
partie de la population brésilienne 7
étiquette là et je trouve aussi que
quand on regarde les cartes électorales
c'est très impressionnant comme on a le
Brésil des classes moyennes qui a voté
plutôt pour bolsonaro et donc c'est les
États du Sud et on a le Brésil des
classes plus populaires et plus pauvres
qui a été massivement pour Lula c'est
donc tous les États du Nord-Est et
clairement
même géographique géographiquement très
forte un mot oui je voulais juste
ajouter sur la partie de la corruption
moi je pense que une des erreurs du PT
et même de Lula et d'ailleurs il a un
peu reconnu c'est à dire que il n'a
reconnu le problème de la corruption que
lors du premier débat de cette campagne
du premier tour et très honnêtement je
peins moi je me sens que c'est quelque
chose que ils auraient dû assumer depuis
longtemps parler depuis longtemps et
quand on dit que la justice a blanchi
Lula c'est pas tout à fait ça en fait il
n'a plus de chat ça c'est vrai la
justice a pris position il y a
absolument aucune poursuite qui qui est
tout est levée mais en fait c'est pour
un vice de forme et on comprend pourquoi
parce qu'on sait au combien aujourd'hui
on le sait la faire a été en fait au
départ il y a une affaire de corruption
qui après il y a beaucoup de
manipulations avec le juge Moreau qui
était entré au gouvernement bolsonaro
mais en revanche Lula en fait ce qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui c'est qu'il est ni
coupable ni innocent mais la sanction
est levée mais il y a pas une décision
il y a aucune décision de justice au
Brésil qui a innocenté Lula et je pense
que ce trouble là puisqu'on est dans ce
ça reste dans les esprits bien sûr parce
que les gens aussi subis la corruption
précédemment jouant Whitaker voulait
intervenir à ce que vous dites justement
concernant Lula Johan Whitaker oui je
pense que il faut voir les choses avec
un peu de d'attention d'abord la
victoire de Lula était de justesse mais
il faut quand même le dire qu'il y a eu
des des événements assez importants
pendant la journée du dimanche et en
plus de fait que dans dernier mois
bolsonaro a mis de l'argent public dans
la campagne d'une manière complètement
illégale et que nous avons eu des des
barrages faits par la police des routes
et par l'armée à Rio qui ont empêché les
gens d'aller voter dans plusieurs États
et surtout les États du Nord-Est ce qui
a été mis en place par le propre
bolsonaro depuis le 19
octobre dernier donc c'était quelque
chose de préparé et on ne peut pas
savoir à quel point ces opérations ont
en effet empêcher des gens d'aller voter
c'est à dire que il y a encore quelque
chose à voir c'est à dire est-ce que
cette différence insérer a vraiment été
la différence réelle ou est-ce que les
tentatives complètement
antidémocratiques et autoritaire de
bolsonaro ont effectivement eu un effet
assez dévastateur il faudra voir ça dans
les jours à venir ensuite je voudrais
juste corriger une chose il y a une
différence entre de la corruption dans
le gouvernement du pété qui restait 14
ans au pouvoir et comme tous les
gouvernements il y a eu beaucoup
d'affaires et effectivement et une
question de corruption de Lola lui-même
Lola lui-même a été innocenté il a été
présenté par la Cour suprême par suprême
non non les charges ont été levés parce
que la Cour suprême a décidé que tout
était le juge que le juge
quel professeur de droit constitutionnel
au Brésil il va vous expliquer par
rapport à la décision qui a été prise il
n'y a pas le à aucun moment la justice a
pris la décision qu'il a été innocenté
demander aux correspondants du monde il
a même un indice que moi parce que nous
on est journaliste on est neutre et nous
on s'est renseigné auprès de juristes et
et ça n'empêche en fait ce qu'il faut
dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui il n'est ni
coupable ni innocent voilà on en est à
ce stade là il y a une annulation et de
ses condamnations
et il n'a pas d'accusation contre lui ça
c'est une chose ont été considérées
complètement mais non c'est pas une
décision innocente
et qui était justement le principal
assesseur de Lola de bolsonaro lors de
cette campagne le juge qui a construit
les accusations
que le juge n'était pas était totalement
partial n'empêche pas la situation
entre la corruption de Lula et la
corruption sous le gouvernement je pense
que c'est ça qui a été mis en cause et
qu'il faut quand même un peu discerner
je vais laisser Armel unders pour
répondre elle voulait réagir sur deux
choses d'une part sur je trouve qu'on
passe beaucoup trop de temps sur ces
affaires de corruption concernant le
lendemain Lula parce que s'il faut faire
un procès de la corruption Brésil là on
peut faire un débat là-dessus et c'est
pas le c'est pas lu là ni le Parti des
travailleurs qui ont sortiront le plus
éclaboussé le le c'est pas le péter qui
a le plus de procès et d'affaires et de
condamnation
après les affaires
donc c'est ce sont justement les parties
du syndrome qui ont soutenu au bolsonaro
et tous les partis politiques toutes les
gouvernement mais donc c'est ça on perd
un temps sur les corruptions du PT il
faut parler d'autre chose alors pour
revenir sur les pressions je pense que
c'est alors c'est une chose très grave
un crime électorale qui a été commis par
la police routière fédérale et par les
forces armées il y a eu des faits très
importants je suis pas sûr que c'est ça
qui est pesé sur le résultat mais en
tout cas ce sans doute peser sur le
résultat c'est le déferlement de fake
news entre les deux tours la justice
électorale a fait ce qu'elle a pu pour
essayer d'éviter ce déferlement ce qui
avait eu lieu en 2018 mais on a beau
interdire les choses une fois que la
rumeur est disséminée le mal est fait et
ça ça a été épouvantable et comme les
gens fonctionnent dans des bulles que
les Brésiliens s'informent par des
réseaux sociaux c'est-à-dire dans leur
propre bulle on a un effet absolument
dévastateur et ça ça a joué et autre
chose qui a joué
bolsonaro a vidé les coffres publics
pour alimenter
au profit de sa campagne avec un budget
secret alors ça si on veut parler de
corruption c'est là qu'il faut en parler
j'aimerais qu'on avance un petit peu
François Michel Letourneau j'ai un
bolsonaro il n'a toujours pas réagi il
doit parler normalement dans
l'après-midi au Brésil en c'est ce
qu'annonce ses alliés c'était prévisible
ce silence qu'est-ce qu'il pourrait dire
tout à l'heure on attendait pas qu'il
soit bonjour donc ça c'est pas c'est pas
très étonnant ce qui est important c'est
qu'un certain nombre de personnages de
l'État donc le président de l'Assemblée
nationale qui est un allié de bolsonaro
le président du Sénat et le procureur
général de la République qui a été nommé
par bolsonaro ont tous reconnu la
victoire de Google
on ne voit pas comment est-ce que le
président pourrait commencer à contester
avec autant de voix qui ont dit que la
victoire était actée et par ailleurs la
seule chose qui est embêtante c'est que
les forces armées n'ont toujours pas
reconnus ou se sont pas véritablement
exprimés peut-être par respect pour le
président en attendant qu'il parle mais
disons que on voit pas pour le moment
surtout de prétexte c'est pas la même
situation aux États-Unis où on peut
toujours pinailler sur le vote d'un État
ou d'un autre faire recompter des
bulletins et tout là le système
électoral brésilien montre sa qualité
contrairement à ce que bolsona on le
disait c'est à dire qu'il est
extrêmement transparent qu'on a le
résultat très rapidement et qu'il est
très difficilement contestable donc pour
le moment on peut difficilement
s'attendre à ça même si on voit que
quelques partisans de bolsonaro
notamment les camionneurs
il y a des pour le moment des incidences
pour addict on va voir comment ça se
développe mais on peut supposer que le
président bolsonaro va devoir sortir de
sa broderie et que il reconnaîtra du
bout des lèvres le résultat en disant
que le monde était contre lui est-ce que
Virginie Jacob berger
Whitaker vous vouliez vous exprimer
juste pour pour confirmer je pense juste
une petite observation c'est je suis
tout à fait d'accord et mais je pense
que le fait que
l'armée n'est pas encore ne se soit pas
prononcé c'est un bon signe et pas un
mauvais signe parce que je pense que
elle est en train de démontrer que ce
n'est pas son rôle
constitutionnellement parlant elle n'a
pas à se prononcer à ce sujet là donc en
fait notre analyse c'est que c'est mieux
que pour l'instant elle le dise rien
parce que ça veut dire que elle est en
train d'accepter et en fait en plus de
ce que vous avez cité il y a aussi les
gouverneurs d'États qui sont alliés à
bolsonaro et qui ont gagné là leur
élection déjà le premier tour qui se
sont déjà prononcés notamment sur Paulo
il a gagné hier ils se sont déjà aussi
prononcés en acceptant la victoire de
l'oula donc tout ça ça fait quand même
un ensemble d'éléments qui nous
permettent dire que la victoire de Lula
est de démocratiquement consolider je
pense Virginie Jacquot berger en même
temps
gerbole sonaru il reste encore au
pouvoir pendant deux mois puisque c'est
seulement en janvier que Lula rentrera
en fonction on sait que j'ai un
bolsonaro c'est un grand admirateur de
Donald Trump est-ce qu'on peut imaginer
un scénario un peu comme aux États-Unis
comme la saut du Capitole par exemple
dans ce laps de temps est très
honnêtement moi je ne pense pas et pour
quelles raisons alors il y a deux choses
il y a le il y a le qu'est-ce qu'il
avait il voulait prendre comme décision
déjà hier à l'issue de la défaite en
fait on voit que pendant le notamment
entre les deux tours de campagne
bolsonaro Ina cessé de dire que
il n'accepterait pas la défaite et puis
le lendemain il a dit exactement le
contraire en fait il est assez cessé de
se contredire donc on pouvait s'attendre
à tout ça c'est une chose ensuite sur le
la possibilité d'une insurrection
manière à ceux du Capitole très
honnêtement moi je pense qu'on est loin
de ce scénario d'abord parce que vous le
voyez très bien ce qu'a dit vos
interlocuteur l'armée ne bouge
absolument pas et il paraîtrait que par
exemple Pierre au palais quand bolsonaro
c'est isolé en fait vous savez il y a
aussi ses fils qui attirent les braises
parce que eux absolument pas lâcher le
pouvoir il y a pas simplement le père
qui veut pas lâcher et l'idée de ne pas
accepter la défaite apparemment c'était
une idée qui circulait dans le clan des
bolsenaro mais il y a eu comme ça un
tournant hier au soir des élections
pour au moment où ce que vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure à retour lira donc le
président de la Chambre des députés
proche de a des a décidé de reconnaître
et c'est quand même la moindre des
choses si les institutions sont
respectées la victoire de Lula ensuite
je pense quand même qu'il y a une chose
qu'il faut qu'on rappelle moi je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec vous sur la
manière dont bolsonaro a essayé de faire
ses enveloppes d'acheter en fait des
voix ce qui est quand même assez
incroyable je trouve dans son attitude
de ne pas intervenir en faisant un
discours c'est aussi
utégar aux personnes qui ont voté pour
lui puisque c'est quand même beaucoup de
Brésiliens
qui soient pas intervenu pour ne
serait-ce que les remercier d'avoir voté
pour lui et puis normalement quand on
respecte la démocratie effectivement on
admet sa défaite et on intervient et en
revanche j'aimerais revenir sur ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure sur la
corruption moi je ne suis absolument pas
d'accord sur le fait qu'il faut passer à
autre chose parce que ça fait partir de
l'histoire du Brésil je pense que tant
qu'on n'aura pas fait face à ça à ce
problème là et au problème de justice
qui n'ont pas été je pense que ça
explique beaucoup pourquoi le prix le à
ce point fracturé et la preuve en est
c'est que dans le scrutin de l'élection
puisqu'on dit ça a été une victoire au
rasoir on le voit bien dans les scores
il y a aussi une un paramètre dont on a
peu évoqué à mon avis vu d'ici c'est le
nombre d'abstention il y a eu un nombre
record d'abstention alors quand on dit
20 % au premier tour il y a eu 20 %
d'abstention c'est rien ici mais pour un
vote qui est obligatoire au Brésil ça
c'est quand même énorme j'allais en fait
on le voit bien on voit bien aussi qu'il
y a un certain nombre d'électeurs vous
savez j'aimerais j'aimerais
un mot c'est pas vrai
et ensuite j'aimerais qu'on avance un
petit peu sur les défis qui attendent
Lola
mais l'abstention est toujours autour de
20% Brésil elle était historiquement
record par rapport à les chiffres je
pense que
et puis ensuite on viendra au défi
personnes qui attendent je suis attendre
l'abstention
c'est faux je parlais du premier tour
donc je disais que c'était sur les
réseaux internet de l'abstention je
pense que vous vous trompez mais bon on
va passer à autre chose je pense que je
pense que
bolsonaro en fait c'est un peu
cornérisé tout seul
en attendant en étant silencieux parce
que finalement sa parole a perdu de son
importance les choses sont faites ça a
été dit tout le monde a reconnu donc bah
il va dire quoi qui reconnaissent sa
défaite ça va être je pense que vraiment
il sait un peu démonétisés à cette
question le Brésil est pas un pays
polarisé comme les États-Unis il y a
énormément de partis politiques il est
très fracturé et les hommes politiques
brésiliens vont à la soupe donc en fait
bolsonaro a perdu tout le monde s'en est
rendu compte et maintenant on voit que
même ses alliés comme starcision
etc donc voilà donc il y a une
plasticité des institutions brésiliennes
qui peut être mauvaise dans certains cas
mais qui dans certains cas leur donne
plus d'agilité j'aimerais qu'on fasse un
point on va regarder en images je veux
un whithécaire je vous donnerai la
parole après on va d'abord regarder un
sujet pour revenir sur sur les défis
notamment économiques qui attendent le
nouveau président Lula on va voir dans
quel état il récupère aujourd'hui le
pays
devant ces partisans Lula peut pousser
un ouf de soulagement mais la fête ne
sera que de courte durée tant les
attentes sont énormes à la tribune il
réaffirment l'urgence de combattre la
pauvreté
la tâche la plus essentielle est de
faire en sorte que chaque enfant
chaque femme chaque adolescent chaque
homme puisse prendre un petit déjeuner
un déjeuner et un dîner tous les jours
33 millions de Brésiliens pennent à
manger à leur faim et le taux de
pauvreté a bondit de 30% en 20
contrairement à 2002 année de son
arrivée au pouvoir Lola hérite cette
fois-ci d'un contexte économique dégradé
risque de récession inflation galopante
mais le plus grand défi qu'il attend
c'est la protection du poumon vert du
Brésil l'Amazonie en proie à la
déforestation pour développer
l'agriculture intensive en 4 ans de
mandat bolsonaro près de 40 000 km² de
forêt ont été rasés l'équivalent d'un
pays comme la Suisse un désastre
écologique pour l'un des plus grands
puits à carbone de la planète autre
enjeu de taille présidé un pays marqué
par les divisions la courte victoire de
Lulla montre un pays profondément
polarisé avec une politique ciblant
particulièrement les minorités
nous envoyons les conséquences là dans
la rue tous les jours nous l'avons subi
car nous sommes noirs de gauche car nous
sommes des femmes parce que nous
défendons la vie toutes les personnes de
ce pays l'éducation
c'est de se rendre compte que presque
encore 50% de la population et pour
bolsonaro c'est frustrant moi qui ai été
ici à signalandia à défendre toutes les
luttes après l'élection s'ouvre
désormais une période de transition qui
mènera à l'investiture de Lula en
janvier si elle est d'ordinaire
respectée Jr bolsonaro avait laissé
planer le doute sur sa volonté de
reconnaître une éventuelle défaite et de
faciliter l'arrivée de son successeur
bien sûr vous avez soutenu Lula Lula qui
va devoir redresser l'économie
brésilienne économie qui est plutôt mal
en point et ça pourrait être compliqué
puisque Lula il a pas la majorité au
Congrès et puis de nombreux
entrepreneurs soutiennent aujourd'hui
Jérôme
oui effectivement je voudrais juste
passer quelques chiffres en fait
l'abstention en 2018 a été de 20,3 cette
année elle a été de 25 20 95 au premier
tour et les descendue à 257 au deuxième
tour donc nous sommes à peu près
dire je voudrais dire qu'effectivement
Lola aura un gouvernement très difficile
parce que il faut qu'il compose avec
d'abord une grande une
un très grand nombre de personnes qui
pensent très différemment le Brésil et
ensuite parce qu'il y a certains points
qui ont déjà été décidé de par exemple
le budget de l'année prochaine à aider
déjà voté cette année par exemple le
budget secret qui a été encore un
élément de corruption qui a été repris
par le président de Solaro et qui a
quand même près de 4 milliards de
d'euros qui sont impliqués dans ce
budget secret donc ça veut dire Lula
aura je pense un premier moment de
quelques de pas mal de bois où il va
devoir mettre en place réarranger la
maison comme on dit pour pouvoir essayer
de voir un horizon un peu plus un peu
plus ouvert et un peu plus clair à
partir du deuxième semestre de 2023 je
pense que ça va pas être facile parce
qu'en plus il faut se rappeler que il
doit travailler avec une assemblée avec
un congrès national qui ne lui est pas
favorable c'est à dire que le Brésil a
ce problème d'un présidentialisme très
dépendant justement d'avoir un appui au
Parlement et donc Lola va devoir
négocier une encore plus grande portée
de ses appuis qui va même dans les
parties qui aujourd'hui ont appuyé
bolsonaro donc ça va pas du tout être
facile vous avez tout à fait raison mais
je pense que ce qu'on a dit au début du
débat c'est maintenant on est soulagé et
maintenant on peut y penser avec un peu
plus de calme parce que jusqu'à
maintenant on était vraiment
complètement renversé par une logique
qui était une logique de la violence une
logique de la mort une logique de la
destruction une logique de
l'inacceptation de toutes les
différences qui heureusement rien que ça
ça change un peu la morale et l'humeur
générale dans le pays je pense que c'est
très important carmelenders l'arrivée de
Lula ça va changer le moral du pays
c'est quoi sa priorité ça va être
s'attaquer à la pauvreté la pauvreté qui
a augmenté alors la pauvreté a augmenté
on est il y a un retour en arrière quand
même par rapport à il y a une vingtaine
d'années mais à cause aussi de la
conjoncture internationale
à cause des choix qui ont été faits ces
dernières années aussi
alors le moral pour la petite majorité
de Brésiliens et sans doute il y a pas
que des électoraux au Brésil au-delà ça
c'est certainement ça redonne l'espoir
enfin c'était visible aujourd'hui dans
les dans les messages que j'ai pu que
j'ai pu lire pour l'autre partie en
revanche c'est c'est bien sûr ce que
disait François Michel Letourneau c'est
un c'est autre chose c'est un moment de
c'est un moment de d'angoisse sans doute
pour pour Lula il y a un fil conducteur
donc toute la carrière de Lula dans
toute dans sa vie politique c'est la
lutte contre la faim pour lui c'est je
crois le voilà l'alpha le but son
objectif politique depuis qu'il est
rentré en politique c'est ça c'est que
les Brésiliens fassent trois repas par
jour il l'a dit en 2002 il a dit même
avant dans les autres campagnes
électorales il a dit donc pendant sa
campagne de 2002 quand il était les
programmes qu'il a mis en place c'était
fin zéro et il a redit il le sait c'est
constant et aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le
cas pour 15 % des Brésiliens
donc ça c'est son objectif et il fera ce
qu'il faut pour ça y compris des
compromis et des compromissions parce
que le Brésil ça ne se il y a une
corruption systémique et on ne gouverne
pas sans
descend des des échanges sans de Luna il
est très fort pour ça Lola qui a promis
aussi beaucoup pour l'environnement on
va l'écouter
nous allons rétablir une surveillance
accrue de l'Amazonie et lutter contre
toute extraction illégale de minerais
extraction de bois ou défrichement pour
l'agriculture
dans le même temps nous allons
promouvoir le développement durable dans
les communautés de l'Amazonie nous
allons prouver une fois de plus qu'il
est possible de générer de la richesse
sont détruire l'environnement
François Michel Letourneau c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour l'environnement pour
l'Amazonie l'arrivée de Lula au pouvoir
je pense que c'est une bonne nouvelle
effectivement pour l'environnement et
pour l'Amazonie un monsieur où il prend
reprendra probablement la politique de
contrôle donc ce qu'on appelle
commandant de control donc les
institutions vont jouer leur rôle et
faire respecter les règles au moins
autant que possible donc ce serait une
bonne nouvelle après c'est très
symbolique cet objet Amazonie je pense
que cette partie du discours était
plutôt destinée à l'opinion publique
internationale qui ne voit que
l'Amazonie au Brésil les probablement
environnementaux du Brésil transcendent
largement la question de l'Amazonie Lula
n'a pas évoqué la question des
pesticides parce qu'il veut pas se
fâcher avec les agriculteurs il y a
plein de choses comme ça qui n'ont pas
été évoquées donc voilà donc là c'est
plutôt des mots pour l'opinion publique
internationale et pour les dirigeants
internationaux sachant qu'il a rajouté
après ce que on prend pas souvent dans
ces extraits dans le respect de la
souveraineté du Brésil donc ça veut dire
que tout cela se fera dans les règles
brésiliennes et donc il y a par exemple
au Brésil de la déforestation légale
c'est des forestation continuera donc ce
sera pas des forestations zéro mais ce
sera certainement cliquer sur le frein
et c'est une bonne nouvelle
aussi alors surtout moi je voulais
revenir sur cette expression je pense
qu'il faut faire attention au discours
qui tient aussi parce que quand il y a
des promesses comme ça quand ça commence
avec justement cette expression de
déforestation zéro on sait très bien que
c'est une promesse qui peut pas être
tenue parce qu'en fait c'est pas ça ce
qui va se passer ou effectivement on
sait qu'il y aura un problème parce que
ça s'est passé comme ça dans les moments
d'après ces dents l'agrobusiness il faut
bien voir que ça a été toujours une
puissance très importante dans
l'économie brésilienne mais surtout
qu'aujourd'hui l'économie n'a jamais été
autant dépendante de de l'agrobusiness
et qu'en plus c'est un lobby politique
extrêmement important et que Lula sera
bien obligé de composer avec et par
ailleurs sur le problème de la
déforestation au Brésil mais vous vous
êtes un spécialiste donc c'est plutôt à
vous d'intervenir sur cette question là
mais il faut aussi voir que le problème
de la déforestation ça dépasse largement
le cadre de la forêt amazonienne et ce
qui concerne notamment la zone du
Serrado qui dépend aussi et où là où la
gros business intervient et que
là-dessus Lula ne fera sans doute pas
beaucoup de promesses et sans doute
phrase avec et quand aux pesticides je
pense que le Brésil bat enfin en tout
cas partie des pays qui battent le plus
de records mais pour revenir à ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure moi je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec sur le point que le
la priorité aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement l'aide sociale le Brésil
est dans une situation
on va dire même socialement fragile
d'abord ça a toujours été un pays
extrêmement inégalitaire mais
aujourd'hui
ben moi j'ai vraiment vu en contactant
des jeux enfin en étant en contact avec
des gens de la classe moyenne se
décrochage c'est à dire que les plus
pauvres sont retournés à la fin
effectivement c'est Lula qui avait sorti
les Brésiliens de la fin et les
minorités sont aussi des gens qui
étaient un peu la classe moyenne qui
aujourd'hui se sont appauvris donc tout
tout toutes ces brésiliens qui sont
attendent beaucoup dans un contexte
économique international malheureusement
on le sait tous qui est beaucoup moins
favorable et je pense qu’économiquement
il y a aussi donc puisqu'on parle de
l'agrobusiness un vrai problème du
Brésil on a parlé au Venezuela d'une
manette diction du pétrole il y a aussi
un peu une malédiction des matières
premières c'est à dire que tant que le
Brésil ne se transformera pas
économiquement ne sera il faut qu'il
devienne moins dépendant de ces matières
premières parce que on ne change pas un
pays sans changer cette répartition de
de l'économie brésilienne et par
ailleurs les inégalités je pense que
tant qu'il y aura pas un effort
considérable qui sera fait c'est ce qui
a manqué vous savez quand dyma avant la
destitution de Dean Mark Rousseff les
Brésiliens sont allés alors qu'ils font
rarement des manifestations dans la rue
ils sont allés dans la rue pour réclamer
quoi pour réclamer plus d'éducation et
plus de santé ça prouve bien que les
mandats et notamment elle précédemment
n'avaient pas assez investi dans le
social donc il faut que demain cette
promesse soit tenue là ils ont eu quatre
ans ils ont été mis au régime sec
d'éducation et de santé donc voilà
ce qui s'est passé ces dernières années
aussi ça n'empêche pas l'autre un mot un
moyen de réagir qui a été dit oui il y
aurait beaucoup de choses à dire il y
aurait beaucoup de choses à dire bon là
s'il y a un point où les gouvernements
ont pétaient ont aussi fait des efforts
c'est bien l'éducation l'enseignement
supérieur l'accès à l'enseignement
supérieur la recherche et ça nous les
liens sont allés dans la rue pour
réclamer quand même la désirer du
service public
l'éducation et la santé parce que tout
allait à la corruption quoi et
malheureusement
vous expliquer qui sont allés dans la
rue en 2014 ils ont bien réclamé plus
d'éducation et de santé dans le pays
j'aimerais j'aimerais
s'exprimer on va on va l'écouter tout de
suite Jean Whitaker je vous écoute on
vous écoute oui non juste dire que sur
l'éducation je vais même pas rentrer de
sur ce thème parce que c'est très très
reconnu ici que
le gouvernement lui là avec notamment
Fernando Haddad a doublé le nombre
d'universités publiques pendant sa
gestion il a mené le nombre d'étudiants
de l'université de 2 millions à 8
millions pendant
les de le lundi de ma donc ça a été une
révolution dans l'éducation je voudrais
juste te dire au sujet de l'Amazonie
quelque chose d'assez symptomatique
c'est que il y a eu dans la dans les
votations quand on voit les États qui
font la périphérie de l'Amazonie le
cercle autour de l'Amazonie ils ont tous
été eu la victoire de bolsonaro ce sont
justement les États où se passe la
déforestation où se passe le
défrichement autour de la monoculture et
du bois et c'est là les États où il y a
eu le plus de cas qu'on pourrait on
appelle ici de harcèlement politique ça
veut dire de propriétaire d'entreprises
de bois etc qui faisait des du chantage
avec leurs employés pour qu'ils votent
votre bolsonaro alors que dans l'État
d'amazona lui-même ça veut dire l'état
de la forêt lui-même Lula a gagné alors
ce sont des chiffres qui montrent un peu
comment justement bolsonaro qui faut se
souvenir à la question par exemple des
pesticides ces bolsonaro qui a ouvert
les portes il a plus que doublé les de
pesticides au Brésil pendant sa gestion
donc il va y avoir quand même je pense
une réaction assez forte c'est évident
que on ne peut pas dire qu'en Amazonie
il y aura une déforestation zéro du jour
au lendemain mais on était sur une voie
quand même beaucoup plus civilisatrice
que ce que l'on a eu pendant les 4 ans
de destruction totale de bolsonaro ça
c'est sûr il nous reste 2 minutes
j'aimerais juste vous poser une question
sur la future politique étrangère de
Lula Lula qui affirmé que le Brésil
était de retour sur la scène
internationale que le Brésil ne serait
plus un paria Armel Anders ça va passer
par quoi juste un mot un petit tour de
table et puis ça va je pense qu'il a une
expérience internationale extrêmement
forte ou là c'est quand même le
président brésilien qui avait mis le
Brésil au cœur qu'on a fait un acteur
important des relations internationales
donc il veut reprendre cette cette
expérience là et puis effectivement là
aussi c'est un point sur lequel il
divergent complètement de bolsonaro qui
a été isolé cette isolé de partout et
complètement c'est quelqu'un qui ne
voyagait pas du tout et qui ne voyagent
pas donc c'est c'est clair que là on a
un retour du Brésil comme un acteur et
en même temps François mitaine bolsonaro
était un échec complet surtout un chaos
complet personne n'a jamais compris ce
qui voulait faire en politique
extérieure sont ministre des Affaires
étrangères en fin le premier était
absolument illisible donc du coup quoi
que lu la fasse si c'est à peu près
ordonné si ça reprend les canons de
l'État brésilien parce qu'il y a une
diplomatie brésilienne qui a une longue
histoire et qui fonctionnait bien déjà
ça le Brésil sera de lui-même de retour
sur la scène internationale lui égard à
sa puissance économique et à son dans le
monde un dernier mot oui si on peut
justement on l'a bien vu dans les
félicitations d'Emmanuel Macron de tous
les présidents en fait Emmanuel Macron
qui a dit vouloir renouer le lien
d'amitié entre la France alors qu'on
voit bien qu'il y avait plus aucun enfin
effectivement il y avait un isolement
diplomatique qui était quand même
considérable et ça c'est vraiment
complètement de la responsabilité de
bolsonaro et ce qui va se passer
aujourd'hui il faut voir que de la
figure de Lula on le sait là pour le
coup c'est quand même un animal
politique incroyable il y a aucun
président de toute l'histoire du Brésil
qui a réussi à faire trois mandats il a
7 à tout là il a des contacts donc et
aussi le la responsabilité avec beaucoup
de relations diplomatiques on voit
d'ailleurs qu'il y a déjà des visites
même les Américains veulent envoyer le
jack Sullivan cette semaine au Brésil
donc il y a tout un jeu diplomatique et
je peux vous dire que même les les
diplomates dites à marathy le
l'équivalent du Quai d'Orsay sont
absolument enfin poussent eux aussi un
peu peut-être pas tous mais beaucoup un
ouf de soulagement de la reprise de ces
relations internationales j'aimerais
juste rajouter un point on a plus du
tout le temps la poutine parce qu'en
revanche là il y aura un problème à
résoudre avec la guerre en Ukraine reste
Lola qui reste toujours proche
exactement de la Russie c'est ce qu'il a
c'est ce qu'il a dit exactement merci
beaucoup merci à tous les quatre merci
François le tournoi merci Virginie Jacob
berger Armel Anders c'est Jean Whitaker
depuis Sao Paulo c'était le débat restez
avec nous sur France 24 l'information
continue